طهران بدورها ترد بلا مواربه هي الاخرى اي
استهداف لمنشاتها النوويه له معنى واحد في
قاموسها الحرب الشامله
لاستطاع اخر تطورات المتعاقبه في هذا
الملف تنضم الينا من القدس نجوان سمري ومن
طهران مراسل الجزيره عمر هواش ابدا معك
نجوان ما هي اخر المواقف حتى الان
نعم دعنا نشير انه ايضا وفقا لوسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه فقد نشرت بانه تم ابلاغ وزراء
هي المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر ما يعرف
بالكبنه لشؤون السياسيه والامنيه الحساسه
في اسرائيل بانه سيتم عقد جلسه في الوقت
القريب او في الايام القريبه المقبله
لاطلاعهم او لبحث تداعيات
وامكانيات ربما اي تدهور على الجبهه
الشماليه اذا هي جلسه خاصه للمجلس الوزاري
الامني المصغر ستعقد قريبا فيما يتعلق
بالجبهه الشماليه وفي اشاره بطبيعه الحال
الى الحدود مع لبنان لكن حتى الان غير
واضح بعد طبيعه هذه الجلسه
ومواعيدها المحدد وانما فقط تم ابلاغ
الوزراء بانه ستكون هناك جلسه قريبا
للمجلس الوزاري بالعاده هذا المجلس يلتئم
فقط عند وجود حالات معينه من الطوارئ بشكل
عام حالات الدخول في معركه في حرب او وقف
ايضا الحرب او المعارك بالاضافه الى امور
امنيه وسياسيه حساسه اخرى في داخل اسرائيل
من جهه اخرى راينا ان رئيس الحكومه ايضا
مع بدء ربما بحث قضيه الموازنه العامه في
اسرائيل في الهيئه العامه للكنيست هذه
الليله والتي يتوقع ان تستمر حتى مساء يوم
غد القى كلمه امام احزاب ائتلافه الحاكم
تحدث فيها عن انجازات حققتها هذه الحكومه
ومفاجات بحسب وصفه للمعارضه او حققتها
الحكومه بالنسبه للمعارضه ومنها ذكر بان
اسرائيل ايضا تقوم بمفاجاه ايران طيله
الوقت وانها ستواصل مفاجاه من وصفهم
باعدائها هذه التصري تاتي في خضام تصريحات
متتاليه لمسؤولين اسرائيليين عسكريين
وامنيين وسياسيين تتعلق بالملف الايراني
النووي
والتلويح بان اسرائيل تخطط او تستعد
لتوجيه ضرب عسكريه
للمفاعلات النوويه في ايران بطبيعه الحال
قد تقتصر هذه التصريحات على تهديدات مكرره
وسابقه ايضا من قبل هؤلاء المسؤولين في
السنوات الاخيره الماضيه سمعت مثل هذه
التهديدات تحديدا من رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش السابق وايضا رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي لطالما قال بانه بالفعل هناك
سيناريوهات وخطط عسكريه
عملياتيه قد وضعت من اجل شن ضربات
للمفاعلات النوويه في داخل ايران ولكن هذا
اليوم ربما تتوالى هذه التصريحات مجددا قد
تكون في اطار التهديدات وقد تكون بالفعل
اسرائيل قد توجه اي ضربه
لايران سواء كان في الاراضي الايرانيه
ولكن ايضا قد تواصل شنهجماتها ضده ما
تسميها اهداف ايرانيه وضد طهران عمر هواش
كيف رد الطهران
جمال ايران في نفس الوقت دائما ازاءه
تصريحات الاسرائيليه تقلل اولا من اهميتها
عبر القول انها تحاول تصدير ازمات داخليه
وانها غير قادره على استهداف المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه او انه لا يوجد ضوء
اخضر امريكي بهذا الشان اليوم هيئه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه على لسان المتحدث باسمها
باهروز كمال واندي قال انه لا يمكن انكار
او ازاله القدرات النوويه الايرانيه وان
هذه القدرات باتت محليه وانه لا معنى لاي
تهديدات بشان المنشات النوويه والقدرات
النوويه الايرانيه لكن في نفس الوقت طيران
تؤكد دائما انها مستعده لكافه الاحتمالات
مع اسرائيل مسؤول الايراني للجزيره قال ان
اي اعتداء على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
سيعني حب حربا غير مسبوقه حربا شامله تشمل
المنطقه كانت قد حذرت دائما من ان اي حرب
مع اسرائيل لن تقتصر فقط بين الاراضي
الايرانيه والعمق الاسرائيلي بل انها قد
تشمل مناطق اخرى في المنطقه نظرا لتواجد
اسرائيل في عده مناطق في المحيط الايراني
وتؤكد انها ان ايران سوف ترد دائما على
منطلق اي تهديد او اي عمل عسكري ضدها سواء
انطلق من العمق الاسرائيلي او من اي اراضي
في المنطقه بلدان في المنطقه يتواجد عليها
الاسرائيليون على الرغم جمال من ان ايران
تعرضت لبعض الهجمات ضد منشات نوويه او
منشات عسكريه خلال السنوات الماضيه او
استهداف شخصيات عسكريين ونوويين لكن ايران
تؤكد دائما انها مستعده ويقظه ويدها على
الزينات ضد اي احتمالات ضد اي هجمات
اسرائيليه مباشره تجري دائما منورات
عسكريه في المياه الخليجيه في الداخل
الايراني في محيط واجواء المنشات النوويه
والمنشات العسكريه لتقول انها دائما في
صدد الاستعداد وحتى انها تؤكد
انها بصدد تعزيز قدراتها الصاروخيه
الدفاعيه وهذا التصريح كان فقط قبل ايام
لمسؤول عسكري كبير في الجيش الايراني حتى
ان وفق المعلومات المتوفره لدينا فن طهران
تستعد للكشف عن صاروخ جديد خلال الايام
القليله المقبله بمعنى ان ايران ربما
سياسيا او اعلاميا قد لا تكترث كثيرا لهذه
التصريحات هذا ربما ما يفسر حتى الان عدم
صدور بيان من الخارجيه الايرانيه او اي
تصريح من المؤسسه العسكريه سواء في الجيش
الايراني اول حرس الثوري لكن هذا لا يعني
ان ايران
تحمل الجد وت ؤك
الجزيره في القدس شكرا لكما حتى هذه
اللحظه